Hey, you're listening to Smartlist. It's hosted by Jason Bateman, myself, Sean Hayes, and Will Arnett. Every episode, we bring on a guest that the other two don't know about it, and it's kind of surprise. And, uh, oh, Will? Hey, man. What's going on? Are you okay? I'm just explaining what the show is. No, I know. I didn't want to interrupt. I'm just over here. I'm just, I'm standing my lane. Oh, I mean, you can chime in if you want. No, you had it. You, I feel like...
嘿，欢迎收听《Smartlist》。主持人是杰森·贝特曼、我肖恩·海耶斯，还有威尔·阿奈特。每一集我们都会请来一位另外两人都不知道的嘉宾，这算是一种惊喜。呃，哦，威尔？嘿，伙计。怎么了？你还好吗？我只是在解释这个节目是什么。不，我知道。我不想打断你。我只是在这儿。我只是，我做好我自己的事。哦，我是说，如果你想插话的话可以插话。不，你刚才说得挺好。你，我觉得……
I mean, do you have anything to add? No, I think you covered it all, and I just felt, to be honest, I just felt kind of useless. You were doing the intro, and I'm just sitting here like a chump. Well, you can say something if you want, but I feel like I got it all in. Okay, um, it's Smartlist, and it's super fun. Here we go. Smartlist. You can't go to Europe. I'm sorry, I couldn't hear that. You want to chew it, swallow it.
我是说，你有什么要补充的吗？不，我觉得你已经说得很全面了，老实说，我只是觉得有点没用。你在做开场白，而我像个傻瓜一样坐在这儿。好吧，如果你想说点什么可以说，但我感觉我已经把该说的都说了。好吧，嗯，这是《Smartlist》，它超级有趣。我们开始吧。《Smartlist》。你不能去欧洲。抱歉，我没听清。你想嚼它，把它咽下去。
I'm trying. You know, you're working right now. You don't, do you chew while you're acting? This is, this is, this is serious. Just the scenery. Just the scenery. What is it? What is it today? What's the carbohydrate today? You know, it might be less annoying than whatever you're eating now. It's just eating a banana and just making that sound that everybody loves.
我在努力。你知道，你现在在工作。你，你在演戏的时候会咀嚼吗？这，这，这很严肃。只是布景。只是布景。是什么？今天是什么？今天的碳水化合物是什么？你知道，这可能比你现在吃的任何东西都让人不那么心烦。只是吃根香蕉，发出那种大家都喜欢的响声。
That kind of sound. Should I do that? Try it. No, what is it? What do you have going today? Today, I was just having a, I was having the end of a little bit of a cookie. Oh, bless. Did you earn it? Oh my God. I did a huge workout and a hike and everything. What did you blast today? Was it tries or buys?
那种声音。我应该那样做吗？试试看。不，那是什么？你今天在忙什么？今天，我只是在吃，我在吃一块饼干的最后一点。哦，天哪。你赚到它了吗？哦，天哪。我做了大量的锻炼，还去徒步旅行，什么都做了。你今天“轰炸”了什么？是三头肌还是买买买？
Do me a favor. Don't say blast. Yeah. Well, isn't that what you always say? It's so gross. Oh, I just blasted my quads. Just blasted me. That's such a gross word. I had my trainer come over and blasted my quads. Listener. Listener. He's wearing a white, really stretched out Nehru t-shirt today.
帮我个忙。别说“轰炸”。是啊。好吧，那不是你一直说的吗？太恶心了。哦，我刚刚轰炸了我的股四头肌。简直轰炸了我。那是个太恶心的词了。我让我的教练过来，轰炸了我的股四头肌。听众朋友们。听众朋友们。他今天穿着一件白色的、领口拉得很开的尼赫鲁T恤。
It's not a Nehru. It's a Henley. Same thing. It's almost looks like you're trying to make us believe that your muscles are breaking through the shirt when really that shirt would fit fine if it was the normal size. This is an extra large baby size. So this is for like a really large baby. For a baby that just got his cookie because he was good today. Baby did get his cookie.
那不是尼赫鲁衫。那是亨利衫。都一样。看起来你好像在试图让我们相信你的肌肉快要把衬衫撑破了，但实际上如果那是正常尺码的话，那件衬衫会很合身。这是一个超大号的婴儿尺码。所以这是给那种非常大的婴儿穿的。给那个因为今天表现好而得到饼干的婴儿。婴儿确实得到了他的饼干。
Listen, fellas. Yeah. Today we're going to make a real dent in our smartness. Okay. Today we have a scientist. Oh, I love it already. This is a PhD. He is the co-founder of several biotechnology companies.
听着，伙计们。是啊。今天我们要让我们的聪明才智大放异彩。好的。今天我们请到了一位科学家。哦，我已经爱上这个主意了。这是一位博士。他是几家生物技术公司的联合创始人。
He's an inventor of 35 patents. He is a co-director at the Harvard Medical School and he has been named one of Time magazine's 100 most influential people. He is also a three time runner up of People magazine's sexiest man of the year. I'm not sure if that's... Wow. We're going to have to ask him about that. Sean, Will and Listener.
他是35项专利的发明者。他是哈佛医学院的联合主任，并被《时代》杂志评为100位最具影响力人物之一。他还是《人物》杂志年度最性感男人三次亚军。我不确定那是不是……哇。我们得问问他关于那个的事。肖恩、威尔和听众朋友们。
This is Dr. David Sinclair. Dr. Oh, wow. Now look. Now that's a sexy man right there. Sexy, right? Yeah. So that's not true, right?
这位是戴维·辛克莱博士。博士。哦，哇。现在看看。那才是一个性感的男人。性感，对吧？是啊。所以那不是真的，对吧？
Three time runner up to the... Did I just add that? It was only two. It wasn't three. That's an exaggeration. Just a two time runner up. It was four. Right.
三次亚军……是我刚才加上去的吗？只有两次。不是三次。那是夸张了。只是两次亚军。是四次。对。
A quick shot of you with that beard on. I bet you're going to win it this year. It's nice. David, thank you very, very much for joining us. Now guys, I will tell you, I had the pleasure of listening to David speak at a small, casual sort of lecture-ish thingy. At someone's house? At someone's house.
快速拍一张你留着胡子的照片。我敢打赌你今年会赢。那很不错。戴维，非常非常感谢你加入我们。现在伙计们，我告诉你们，我有幸听过戴维在一个小型、随意的讲座之类的场合演讲。在某人家里？在某人家里。
And it really knocked me out. Hollywood doesn't write, don't they? They just bring people in. No, listen. Like, you know what? Bring somebody smart over here and let them talk to us. Right, David? Basically, I know.
那真的让我大开眼界。好莱坞不写剧本，对吧？他们只是把人带进来。不，听着。就像，你知道吗？带个聪明人过来，让他们跟我们谈谈。对吧，戴维？基本上，我知道。
They couldn't get anyone else. So I wasn't bothered. I know how it works. And he said some things that really straightened me out as far as my knowledge of general health and mortality. He's a specialist in aging. And I'm going to let him talk to you about some of the things that really knocked me out. I'm going to tee you up here, David.
他们找不到别人了。所以我没被打扰。我知道它是怎么运作的。他说了一些真正让我理清思路的话，关于我对一般健康和死亡率的认知。他是衰老方面的专家。我要让他跟你们谈谈那些真正让我大开眼界的事情。我要为你做个铺垫，戴维。
There is, and please tell me how dumb I am and how much I did not remember. All of us are just him. Just David, the qualified folks. Basically, the just I got, and then I'd love to hear all the specifics again, is that while there is a definite that we're all going to die, science and technology has now sort of given us an opportunity to have a little bit more to say about how we die, when we die, the way in which the end of our life can be enjoyed. Those are all my dumb words, but is that generally what you guys are focused on a lot?
有，请告诉我我有多蠢，以及我记住了多少。我们所有人只是他。只是戴维，合格的人。基本上，我得到的，然后我很乐意再听一遍所有的细节，就是虽然我们肯定都会死，但科学和技术现在给了我们一个机会，让我们对我们如何死、何时死，以及我们生命终点享受的方式有更多的话语权。这些都是我笨拙的措辞，但你们是不是主要关注这些？
And hopefully you'll give us some tips on how to improve that part of our life today. Yeah, sure. I think you guys all know I'm 106. 106. Listener, if you could see this guy, he doesn't look a day over 30. And it's pretty impressive. Yeah. And I didn't pay you to say that.
希望你今天能给我们一些关于如何改善我们那部分生活的建议。是啊，当然。我想你们都知道我106岁了。106岁。听众朋友们，如果你们能看到这家伙，他看起来一点都不像超过30岁的人。这相当令人印象深刻。是啊。而且我没付钱让你这么说。
That's very kind of you. But we're exactly the same age, Jason. We are, aren't we? I think I remember that from that day. I've always thought that I looked fairly young from my age at 51. Did you? David. I mean, come on.
你太客气了。但我们年龄完全一样，杰森。我们是，对吧？我想我记得那天的事。我一直认为以我51岁的年纪，我看起来相当年轻。你觉得吗？戴维。我是说，得了吧。
You always thought that. I have always thought that. I haven't asked anybody to confirm that. But when I look at myself every morning, noon and night, I'm like, oh, look at you. But David doesn't look older than 35, does he? Yeah. Why do you look? Your skin is incredible, actually.
你一直这么认为。我一直这么认为。我没要求任何人证实这一点。但当我每天早晨、中午和晚上看着自己时，我心想，哦，看看你。但戴维看起来不超过35岁，对吧？是啊。你为什么看起来？你的皮肤简直不可思议。
Well, there's this thing on this software we're using. It's called the filter. It works really well. You guys should use it. Yeah. All right. Great. Okay.
嗯，我们用的这个软件上有个东西。它叫滤镜。效果非常好。你们应该用用。是啊。好吧。太棒了。好的。
First of all, you know that Jason's, you and Jason are the same age. I don't know. Maybe you've already Googled us, but you have to guess my age and also Sean's age. Oh, come on. Come on. Come on. Yeah. Well, here we'll qualify.
首先，你知道杰森，你和杰森年龄一样。我不知道。也许你已经谷歌过我们了，但你得猜猜我的年龄，还有肖恩的年龄。哦，得了吧。得了吧。得了吧。是啊。好吧，我们来限定一下。
I want you to, I want you to guess your age and then tell us how will they actually look. I want you to guess it and then tell us what they actually look like. Go ahead. Yeah. I'm going to regret this so bad. Stop making faces. Well, just look normal.
我想要你，我想要你猜猜你的年龄，然后告诉我们他们实际上看起来多大。我想要你猜一下，然后告诉我们他们实际上看起来像什么。开始吧。是啊。我会非常后悔这一点的。别做鬼脸。好吧，看起来正常点。
Don't be nice. Like if you think we're older or whatever you want to do, just really guess. Well, you know, I have the advantage. I've been watching all of you for a number of years. So I kind of know when you popped onto the scene. Only a couple of years for me because I just got started. Yeah, that's true. I would have said 26 for Will.
别太客气。就像如果你觉得我们更老或者你想怎么做，就真的猜一下。嗯，你知道，我有优势。我已经看了你们所有人好几年了。所以我大概知道你们是什么时候出现在公众视野里的。对我来说只有几年，因为我才刚开始。是啊，那是真的。我会说威尔26岁。
Sure. I think we're all pretty similar in age. I don't know. I think maybe Sean, you're a bit younger, but the rest of us have been around for a while. Yeah, by a decade. Is that right? Yeah. You're 41, Sean.
当然。我觉得我们年龄都差不多。我不知道。我想也许肖恩，你稍微年轻一点，但我们其他人已经混迹一段时间了。是啊，早了十年。是这样吗？是啊。你41岁，肖恩。
I'm 41. Bullshit. I also am a half a century old. 50. Wow. Thanks to you guys. Well, so listen, so we're all okay. I just turned 50.
我41岁。胡扯。我也半个世纪了。50岁。哇。多亏了你们。好吧，所以听着，我们都没事。我刚满50岁。
Oh, you did? Well, yeah, yeah. But David, in 40 years, we'll probably be not shocked if we die. But based on your research and what you can perhaps share with us today, we can make that decade more enjoyable and perhaps not our last decade. Is this maybe accurate? How will we go about doing that? Yeah, so we're kind of at the level of the Wright brothers.
哦，你满了吗？嗯，是啊，是啊。但戴维，40年后，如果我们死了，我们可能不会感到震惊。但基于你的研究以及你今天可能与我们分享的内容，我们可以让那十年过得更愉快，也许不是我们的最后十年。这准确吗？我们该怎么做呢？是啊，所以我们有点像莱特兄弟那个阶段。
It's 1902. We're figuring out how to glide, but we do know it's possible to fly. So we've done, my colleagues and I, there are about 100 leaders in the world doing this. We call it aging research or longevity research. It's now a fact that modern science is caught up with aging. For a while we ignored it, we thought it was natural, acceptable. That's BS. It's definitely not acceptable.
那是1902年。我们正在弄清楚如何滑翔，但我们确实知道飞行是可能的。所以我们已经做了，我和我的同事们，世界上大约有100位领导者在做这件事。我们称之为衰老研究或长寿研究。现代科学已经赶上衰老了，这是一个事实。有一段时间我们忽视了它，我们认为它是自然的、可接受的。那是胡扯。它绝对不可接受。
It's the greatest cause of pain and suffering on the planet. And if you think heart disease, cancer and Alzheimer's are bad, what do you think causes those, right? Young people don't get those diseases. It's a thousand times aging and one time or 20 times these other drivers of these disease. So my point is, if we can understand what causes aging, slow it and even reverse it and we'll get to that, then these diseases either don't happen or you can take them away. And what I was telling you Jason, which I can now tell everybody who's listening is my
它是地球上痛苦和折磨的最大根源。如果你认为心脏病、癌症和阿尔茨海默病很糟糕，你认为是什么导致了这些，对吧？年轻人不会得这些病。这是衰老的一千倍，而这些疾病的其他驱动因素只有一倍或二十倍。所以我的观点是，如果我们能理解是什么导致了衰老，减缓它甚至逆转它，我们稍后会谈到这一点，那么这些疾病要么不会发生，要么你可以消除它们。我刚才告诉你的，杰森，我现在可以告诉所有正在收听的人，我的
field and my lab at Harvard spent about 20 years figuring out what are the genes that control the aging process. And we've been very successful. We have a handful of genes that seem to regulate all life forms on earth from trees to worms, even humans. And we could even, I could read your genes and tell you what the chances are of you living a long time. But now actually that there's some new stuff which is blowing my mind and, you know, my
领域和我在哈佛的实验室花了大约20年时间弄清楚控制衰老过程的基因是什么。我们非常成功。我们有一小部分基因似乎调节着地球上所有的生命形式，从树木到蠕虫，甚至人类。我们甚至可以，我可以阅读你的基因，告诉你你长寿的机会有多大。但现在实际上有一些新东西让我大吃一惊，而且，你知道，我的
mind takes a lot to be blown because I've seen pretty much everything happen. But what I didn't realize is that aging isn't just slowable. It's actually reversible. And we can do this in mice very easily. We can reverse the age of the eye in a mouse and make them see again, these old mice. We can make them run 150%, 200% on a treadmill after just a few weeks of treating. And so these are the right brother's days, right? Imagine in 20, 30 years we could have no intercontinental air travel eventually go to the moon.
大脑需要很多东西才能被震撼，因为我几乎见过所有事情发生。但我没意识到的是，衰老不仅是可以减缓的。它实际上是可以逆转的。我们可以在小鼠身上非常容易地做到这一点。我们可以逆转小鼠眼睛的年龄，让它们再次看见，这些老鼠。我们可以在治疗几周后让它们在跑步机上跑出150%、200%的成绩。所以这些是莱特兄弟的时代，对吧？想象一下，在20、30年后，我们可能没有洲际航空旅行，最终去月球。
Do you think that you guys could in a lab maybe regrow a sense of humor? Like, would that be possible? No. Yeah, like how would that... Atrophied and gone. I used to like working on that. It is true though that you are able to change the, instead of the gray hair on mice, now they no longer have gray hair.
你认为你们在实验室里也许能重新培育出幽默感吗？就像，那有可能吗？不。是啊，就像那会……萎缩了，没了。我以前喜欢研究那个。不过确实，你能够改变，而不是小鼠身上的灰毛，现在它们不再有灰毛了。
That's not true, is it? Well, some people have done that. That is true. You can now reverse gray hair. Actually, there's a drug on the market for cancer that these patients suddenly... I think it was 11 out of 13 patients got their hair back again, the color. Oh, Sean, Will just parked up. Wait, wait, wait.
那不是真的，对吧？嗯，有些人做到了。那是真的。你现在可以逆转灰发。实际上，市场上有一种治疗癌症的药物，这些患者突然……我想是13个病人中有11个恢复了头发的颜色。哦，肖恩，威尔刚才竖起耳朵了。等等，等等。
What's it called? What's it called? What's it called? Who's got a pen? You need to get cancer first. Wait a minute. This is fascinating to me. Right.
它叫什么？它叫什么？它叫什么？谁有笔？你需要先得癌症。等一下。这对我来说太迷人了。对。
Because like think about it. No, you can't catch cancer or leukemia or... So, in other words, it's all that stuff is in us. And there are things that you can do in your life that are not good things that actually turn those little toggle switches on and now all of a sudden you are on your way to getting cancer or leukemia or diabetes or any of these other things. Speak a little bit of that because that really resonated with me, David. Well, so what really is driving all of these diseases is that our bodies become lexodesical
因为就像想想看。不，你不能感染癌症或白血病或……所以，换句话说，所有这些东西都在我们体内。而且你生活中可以做一些不好的事情，实际上会打开那些小开关，现在突然之间你就走上了患癌症、白血病、糖尿病或任何其他疾病的道路。谈谈那个，因为那真的引起了我的共鸣，戴维。嗯，所以真正驱动所有这些疾病的是我们的身体变得懒散
and unable to fight these diseases. When we're young, if a cancer cell pops up, our bodies destroy it. Or if there's misfolder proteins for Alzheimer's, our bodies destroy it. But we lose that ability to defend ourselves against diseases. And most people don't get that. They think diseases are inevitable. No, if you can stay young, physically young, you don't get them. And what we figured out is only part of it is genetic.
并且无法对抗这些疾病。当我们年轻时，如果出现一个癌细胞，我们的身体会摧毁它。或者如果有阿尔茨海默病的错误折叠蛋白，我们的身体会摧毁它。但我们失去了防御疾病的能力。大多数人不明白这一点。他们认为疾病是不可避免的。不，如果你能保持年轻，身体上年轻，你就不会得这些病。我们弄清楚的是，只有一部分是遗传的。
I know I said the genes are important, but actually only 20% of our longevity and our health in old age is from our parents. The rest is how we live our life. What we eat, when we eat, how much we eat. So 80%, as far as like nature versus nurture, it is nurture basically. 80% of how you live will dictate how you die as opposed to hereditary. And we know that because there are these twins in Denmark that lived very different lives. Well, you know them, yeah?
我知道我说过基因很重要，但实际上我们长寿和老年健康的20%来自我们的父母。其余的是我们如何生活。我们吃什么，什么时候吃，吃多少。所以80%，就先天与后天而言，基本上是后天。你如何生活决定了你如何死亡，而不是遗传。我们知道这一点是因为丹麦有这些双胞胎，他们过着截然不同的生活。嗯，你知道他们，是吧？
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Good. Sorry, David. I know that only part of it is genetic because these twins in Denmark, if they lead very different lives, they have very different lifespans. Got it. So basically, one of the things I remember you saying was that it was sort of very common
哦，是啊。是啊。很好。抱歉，戴维。我知道只有一部分是遗传的，因为丹麦的这些双胞胎，如果他们过着截然不同的生活，他们的寿命就会截然不同。明白了。所以基本上，我记得你说过的一件事是，这在某种程度上非常普遍
for us to kind of die at 50, maybe 100 years ago or further. Like nowadays, you know, you die around 80, 90, 100, whatever. You were saying maybe in like 20 or 30 years, people will look back at this time and say, boy, it's so weird that everybody was okay with dying at 80. We're now living to be 120 because of, you know, not just what David Sinclair taught us and uncovered, but this whole sort of world of technology and science, what you guys are uncovering, yeah? Yeah, for sure.
对于我们来说，在100年前或更早的时候，我们在50岁左右死亡。就像现在，你知道，你在80、90、100岁左右死亡，无论如何。你说也许在20或30年后，人们会回顾这段时间并说，天哪，每个人都接受在80岁死亡真是太奇怪了。我们现在活到120岁，因为，你知道，不仅仅是戴维·辛克莱教给我们和揭示的东西，而是整个技术和科学的世界，你们正在揭示的东西，是吧？是啊，当然。
And multiple technologies are advancing. So we've got some of my technology, which reverses the age of cells. We've got these wearables that are getting better and better. There are blood tests that we can do. I could take your blood, you guys, and tell you. Wait, wait, wait. What's a wearer? I know what an edible is.
而且多种技术正在进步。所以我们有一些我的技术，它逆转了细胞的年龄。我们有这些变得越来越好的可穿戴设备。我们可以做血液测试。我可以抽你们的血，伙计们，然后告诉你们。等等，等等。什么是可穿戴设备？我知道什么是可食用产品。
What's a wearable? You just get stoned from certain attire. It's a sporty bracelet. Wow. It's just like a THC-based clothing. Yeah. It had to come. It had to happen.
什么是可穿戴设备？你只是从某些服装中变得飘飘欲仙。它是一个运动手环。哇。它就像一种基于THC的服装。是啊。它迟早会来的。它迟早会发生。
Yeah, yeah. So what's a wearable, David? Well, so it's one of those watches that'll monitor your heartbeat, and they're getting better and better. They can tell you your blood sugar. I'm wearing a ring that tells me how well I slept and what else I got up to last night. I just found out about that. I was thinking I might get one, because I was doing the thing.
是啊，是啊。所以什么是可穿戴设备，戴维？嗯，所以它是那些能监测你心跳的手表之一，而且它们变得越来越好。它们可以告诉你你的血糖。我戴着一个戒指，它告诉我我睡得有多好，以及昨晚我还干了什么。我刚发现那个。我在想我可能会买一个，因为我当时在做那件事。
I was wearing the Whoop, the sleep band. I was wearing that, and I was wearing the Apple Watch, and I'd wake up in the morning. This is true. And I'd wake up in the morning, and I'd look at how I slept, how many times I woke up and stuff, because I'm a big sleep guy. Right. I go to bed very early, and I wake up early, but I believe in getting a lot of sleep. You're very unemployed.
我戴着Whoop，那个睡眠带。我戴着那个，我还戴着Apple Watch，然后我早上醒来。这是真的。我早上醒来，我会看看我睡得怎么样，我醒了多少次之类的，因为我是个很看重睡眠的人。对。我睡得很早，醒得很早，但我相信多睡觉。你非常失业。
Very unemployed. Sleep will make you live longer, that's for sure. It definitely will, right? Yeah. So sleep is really good. So, I mean, this is great for all the people who go to Jason's movies and watch his shows, because they get a lot of sleep. You're welcome.
非常失业。睡眠会让你活得更长，那是肯定的。它绝对会，对吧？是啊。所以睡眠真的很好。所以，我是说，这对所有去看杰森电影和看他节目的人来说太棒了，因为他们得到了充足的睡眠。不客气。
You're welcome. A little naps here and there. What a service you're doing. Sometimes it's 30 minutes, sometimes it's an hour, sometimes it's an hour and a half, full-length movie, you know, whatever you need. I got all cut. You just put it on and walk away. Look at you.
不客气。这里那里小睡一下。你提供的服务真好。有时是30分钟，有时是一个小时，有时是一个半小时，长篇电影，你知道，无论你需要什么。我全包了。你只要戴上它然后走开。看看你。
That's the prescription from David. So, but listen, David, you know, everybody's interested in reversing the aging process. I mean, it's a topic that I'm sure nobody's not interested in. So tell us about exactly if, unless I'm jumping way far ahead, can you tell us like what those are and what exactly, how does that work? And is it all food-based? Like, is it, is it only have to do with what you eat or, and what can we do on our own? Yeah.
那是戴维的处方。所以，但听着，戴维，你知道，每个人都对逆转衰老过程感兴趣。我是说，这是一个我敢肯定没有人不感兴趣的话题。所以告诉我们确切地，除非我跳得太远了，你能告诉我们那些是什么以及它们确切地，它是如何运作的吗？它是完全基于食物的吗？就像，它是，它只与你吃的东西有关吗，或者，我们自己能做什么？是啊。
There's a lot you can actually do. This isn't rocket science. It's actually, it's going to be easy to cure aging and cancer. In your daily life, what the kind of things that I do are eat less often. Get your heart rate up for at least 10 minutes every day or so. Basically, do what we'll did today is a good start. There you go. And the kind of foods, a lot of people argue, is it meat?
你实际上可以做很多事情。这不是火箭科学。实际上，治愈衰老和癌症会很容易。在你的日常生活中，我做的那种事情是少吃点。每天至少让你的心率加快10分钟左右。基本上，做威尔今天做的事是个好的开始。这就对了。至于食物种类，很多人争论，是肉吗？
Is it not meat? But essentially, you don't want to overload your body with, with protein. Having sometimes when you're lower on protein, so plant-based Mediterranean, that's also very good. And we, as a, you know, group of scientists, people have been saying, oh, eat olive oil, eat, you know, all these plant-based foods, exercise. And nobody really understood until recently why that's good for you. It turns out these genes that we've discovered that control our longevity and make our bodies
是不吃肉吗？但本质上，你不想让你的身体摄入过多的蛋白质。有时蛋白质摄入量低一点，所以植物性地中海饮食，那也非常好。我们，作为一群科学家，人们一直在说，哦，吃橄榄油，吃，你知道，所有这些植物性食物，锻炼。直到最近，没人真正明白为什么这对你有好处。事实证明，我们发现的那些控制我们长寿并使我们的身体
fight aging and disease are triggered by these lifestyles. So we can turn on our bodies defenses. It's called hormesis. Hormesis means what doesn't kill you makes you stronger. And really it's putting your body into a state of defensive mode, because if we just eat stuff and we're sitting around and we just watch Jason's movies, our bodies go get tired and they don't react to the onslaught which we're facing every day with chemicals and DNA damage.
对抗衰老和疾病的基因是由这些生活方式触发的。所以我们可以开启我们身体的防御机制。这叫“毒物兴奋效应”（Hormesis）。毒物兴奋效应意味着杀不死你的会让你更强大。这实际上是让你的身体进入一种防御模式，因为如果我们只是吃东西，我们坐着不动，我们只是看杰森的电影，我们的身体会感到疲倦，它们不会对我们每天面临的化学物质和DNA损伤的冲击做出反应。
And so we have ways to trigger those by being hungry sometimes. I'll tell you specifics in a second, but, but also what's interesting is we've, we've now found certain chemicals that also mimic diet and exercise and give you the benefits or enhance a healthy lifestyle. Yeah, because everybody's looking for a quick fix, pill, anything so they don't have to, you know, exercise or do the things you're saying. They can't eat anything. Yeah.
所以我们有办法通过有时感到饥饿来触发它们。我一会儿告诉你细节，但，但同样有趣的是，我们现在发现了一些化学物质，它们也能模拟饮食和锻炼，并给你带来好处或增强健康的生活方式。是啊，因为每个人都在寻找捷径、药丸，任何东西，这样他们就不必，你知道，锻炼或做你说的事情。他们什么都不能吃。是啊。
Do you have the I just worked out for an hour pill? Yeah. We do. Well, we don't know if they work in humans, but in mice, I can take an old mouse and make it marathon runner. I'll take it. How about I just blasted my quads capsule? Yeah.
你有那种“我刚锻炼了一小时”的药丸吗？是啊。我们有。嗯，我们不知道它们在人类身上是否有效，但在小鼠身上，我可以拿一只老鼠让它成为马拉松选手。我会接受的。我刚轰炸了我的股四头肌胶囊怎么样？是啊。
You might grow some whiskers, but other than that, you'll be really healthy. Super young thighs on will. So how do you find out if you have these, you know, genes that like the respond to it? Yeah. Well, have you guys done your genomes yet? No. What has done your genomes? So there, there are companies, right?
你可能会长出一些胡须，但除此之外，你会非常健康。威尔的大腿超级年轻。那么你怎么知道你是否有这些，你知道，对它有反应的基因呢？是啊。嗯，你们做过基因组检测了吗？没有。谁做过你们的基因组检测？所以那里，有公司，对吧？
There's a famous one, 23andMe. There are others and says people do it and they tell you what variations. So we'll pretty much have the same genes. Four of us are men. So we pretty much have the same genes, but the variations on those genes and how they're controlled depends on how we live, but also what we were born with. But we can read what we got from our parents very easily. I could take your DNA and in my lab tomorrow, tell you what your genome is.
有一个很有名的，23andMe。还有其他的，人们会去做，它们会告诉你有什么变异。所以我们基本上有相同的基因。我们四个人都是男人。所以我们基本上有相同的基因，但这些基因的变异以及它们如何被控制取决于我们如何生活，但也取决于我们与生俱来的东西。但我们可以很容易地读出我们从父母那里得到了什么。我可以拿你的DNA，明天在我的实验室里，告诉你你的基因组是什么。
It used to be a billion dollars. Now it takes it's about a hundred bucks. So there are genes. So the one, there's one called Foxo three, which has it's throughout the animal kingdom. We've got it in worms where it was first discovered. But it's also in whales that can live 300 years. And in our bodies, there are certain variants that are known to be in people that live over a hundred and you can just read it.
过去要十亿美元。现在它只需要大约一百美元。所以有基因。所以那个，有一个叫Foxo 3，它遍布整个动物王国。我们在蠕虫身上有它，它最初是在那里被发现的。但它也存在于能活300年的鲸鱼身上。在我们的身体里，有一些已知的变异存在于活过一百岁的人身上，你可以直接读出来。
So for instance, we all have two copies of each gene and I've got one longevity version and one regular version. And I have three kids with my wife and all three of our kids got two of the best copies. So even if they don't live very well, they have a better chance of making it to 95. Wow. And also here's this, so I have a lot of longevity in my family, my great grandmother died at 105. Three of my grandparents died at 97. Two of them at 97, one at 95, I guess.
所以例如，我们每个人都有每个基因的两个拷贝，我有一个长寿版本和一个普通版本。我和我妻子有三个孩子，我们三个孩子都得到了两个最好的拷贝。所以即使他们生活得不太好，他们也有更好的机会活到95岁。哇。而且这里还有这个，所以我家族中有很多长寿基因，我的曾祖母死于105岁。我的三个祖父母死于97岁。两个死于97岁，一个死于95岁，我想。
We're just going to cut part of this. So I guess I'm saying, is there a medal for that? Like where do I line up for like a trophy or something? It's not a contest. And it usually skips a generation. I used to always, Jason's people all died in boats hauling up nets in the Mediterranean. And they all died at like 42. Okay.
我们只是要剪掉这部分。所以我猜我在说，有奖牌吗？就像我在哪里排队领奖杯之类的？这不是比赛。而且它通常会隔代遗传。我过去总是，杰森的族人都在地中海的船上拉网时死去了。他们都死于42岁左右。好的。
So, but with like a jug of wine broken at their feet. So my question is, I always joke that, you know, people say, why do you smoke cigarettes? And I go, yeah, sometimes I smoke. I said, I have to, because I have to aunt's offset because of the advances in medical science. I know that they're going to make everybody live for so long and I go, I can't keep this going forever. This looks too good. So I need to offset it a little bit. It's unfair to other dudes.
所以，但脚边打碎了一壶酒。所以我的问题是，我总是开玩笑说，你知道，人们说，你为什么抽烟？我说，是啊，有时我抽。我说，我必须抽，因为我必须抵消因为医学进步带来的影响。我知道他们会让每个人活得那么久，我说，我不能永远保持这样。这看起来太好了。所以我需要稍微抵消一下。这对其他男人不公平。
It's unfair because I feel like I'm going to live to be about 130 legit. We can only hope. David, can I come over and will you draw some of my blood? Sure. He cracked himself up on that, David. We can do that. Hey, so. Sorry.
这不公平，因为我觉得我能活到130岁，合法的。我们只能希望。戴维，我可以过去，你会抽我的一些血吗？当然。他自己被那个逗乐了，戴维。我们可以那样做。嘿，所以。抱歉。
My question, my real question was, does that make a difference? All the different sides of my family with all this longevity, does that make a difference at all? Yeah. And can you change that as well? Well, it's difficult to change it, but we're getting better at going in and changing genes using technologies like CRISPR. But yeah, the genes are important, but remember only 20%. So, Will, I'm afraid you're probably not going to make it that long unless you live a healthy lifestyle too. And we know that people who smoke, not occasionally, but a lot, have accelerated biological age, which we can measure now.
我的问题，我真正的问题是，那有区别吗？我家族中所有不同方面的长寿，那有任何区别吗？是啊。而且你也能改变那个吗？嗯，很难改变它，但我们正在变得越来越好，去使用像CRISPR这样的技术进入并改变基因。但是啊，基因很重要，但记住只有20%。所以，威尔，恐怕你可能活不了那么久，除非你也过健康的生活方式。而且我们知道，抽烟的人，不是偶尔，而是经常抽烟的人，有加速的生物学年龄，我们现在可以测量了。
Yeah. So, it might be balancing out. We'll see. We can test it. Okay, good. And you said, you said, depending on what is that word you used, that we have the technology, what was it called? CRISPR. What's CRISPR?
是啊。所以，它可能正在平衡。我们会看到的。我们可以测试一下。好的，很好。你说，你说，取决于你用的那个词是什么，我们有技术，它叫什么？CRISPR。什么是CRISPR？
So, CRISPR is about 10 years ago, scientists discovered that you can go in and actually change an exact part of a cell's DNA with an enzyme. And it's being used right now to fix genetic diseases in the eye and restore vision. And eventually, pretty much every disease, this genetic can be fixed. Wow. That's great. What about diabetes? Hang on a second. What?
所以，CRISPR是大约10年前，科学家发现你可以用一种酶进入并实际改变细胞DNA的精确部分。它现在正被用于修复眼睛中的遗传疾病并恢复视力。最终，几乎每一种遗传疾病都可以被修复。哇。那太棒了。糖尿病呢？等一下。什么？
Yeah, what about diabetes? Potentially. What if, like, Will's got, you know, humorously small feet. So, if he wanted to go from a size five up to, like, a men's size of, like, to change his foot size from a five to a nine, could he go into, like, a crisping tub or something? A crisping tub. I eat plenty of Krispy Kreme. Is there a tub of Krispo that I could go into?
是啊，糖尿病呢？潜在地。如果，就像威尔有，你知道，幽默地小脚。所以，如果他想从5码增加到，就像，男士尺码，就像，改变他的脚码从5到9，他能进入，就像，一个脆化桶（crisping tub）之类的吗？脆化桶。我吃了很多Krispy Kreme。有没有我可以进去的Krispo桶？
Like fries. Once the fries are done, could he put his feet in there? Yeah, I think there's a gene. Jason hasn't been able to feel anything below his navel for about 14 years. So, is there any way that we could revive him, so to speak? Well, the onion rings are done. No. Sorry, David.
就像薯条。薯条炸好后，他能把脚放进去吗？是啊，我想有一个基因。杰森大约14年来一直感觉不到肚脐以下的东西。所以，有没有什么办法我们可以让他复活，可以这么说？嗯，洋葱圈炸好了。不。抱歉，戴维。
The ultimate age reversal, I'd say. What could one do to turn on these beneficial parts of our sort of our stock system here to fight the stuff that shortens our life? Well, it's much easier changing a life than changing your genes. And remember, 80%. So, it's very durable. So, what do I do? I try to skip at least one meal a day. I feel a little bit hungry, but not too bad.
终极年龄逆转，我会说。一个人能做什么来开启我们这种库存系统中那些有益的部分来对抗那些缩短我们寿命的东西？嗯，改变生活比改变基因容易得多。而且记住，80%。所以，它是非常持久的。所以，我做什么？我尽量每天少吃一顿饭。我感到有点饿，但不太糟糕。
Just have a cup of tea. I work out four times a week. So, I'm trying to keep my muscles going and flexible. And then I try to keep my heart running. So, every other day, I'll get my heart rate up. And I try to focus on plant-based foods, though I do like a good burger occasionally. But all of that is good. And then I take a few of the molecules that my lab has worked on as well.
只喝杯茶。我每周锻炼四次。所以，我尽量保持我的肌肉活动和灵活。然后我尽量保持我的心脏运转。所以，每隔一天，我会让我的心率加快。我尽量专注于植物性食物，虽然我偶尔也喜欢吃个好汉堡。但所有这些都很好。然后我也服用一些我的实验室研究过的分子。
Because I remember what you were saying, you alluded to it a few minutes ago, which is if you can trip your system into sort of... I forget the word you used, sort of like a defensive... Chromesis. Yeah. Right, where... And it's triggered sometimes by hunger. Not starvation, but hunger, where the body thinks, Uh-oh, I might be starting to starve here.
因为我记得你说过什么，你几分钟前提到过它，也就是如果你能诱导你的系统进入某种……我忘了你用的词，某种像防御性的……毒物兴奋效应。是啊。对，哪里……而且它有时是由饥饿触发的。不是饥饿，而是饥饿感，身体认为，噢，不，我可能开始挨饿了。
It kind of clicks into this mode that is the molecules, the energy, the proteins, whatever it is, you'll tell us, that actually start to fight the bad stuff. The cancer, the diabetes, the leukemia, whatever it may be. We kind of activate that army and it comes out into our system while we are a little bit hungry. And that sort of speaks to kind of micro-fasting. Yes. Intermittent fasting works. Try to be hungry for...
它有点进入这种模式，即分子、能量、蛋白质，无论它是什么，你会告诉我们，实际上开始对抗坏东西。癌症、糖尿病、白血病，无论它可能是什么。我们有点激活了那支军队，它在我们有点饿的时候进入我们的系统。这有点谈到了微断食。是的。间歇性断食有效。尝试饥饿……
You can do a 16 versus 8 hours, so you can be hungry for 16 hours. Usually, I'll eat dinner at 7 at night and I won't eat until the next day at about noon or one. Perfect. That's kind of perfect, right? Yeah, that's what I do. That's a good way to do it. I'm not sure, you know, drinking whiskey late at night is very good for you. Oh, I have a whiskey drip.
你可以做16对8小时，所以你可以饥饿16小时。通常，我晚上7点吃晚饭，直到第二天中午或一点才吃。完美。那有点完美，对吧？是啊，这就是我做的。那是个好方法。我不确定，你知道，深夜喝酒对你有好处。哦，我有静脉滴注威士忌。
I'm sorry, let that part out. I have a whiskey drip while... Yeah, let him finish, David. Jason's gone as long as 45 minutes without food. Would that be considered good? Like a good run? But it is true. If you don't eat from like 6 p.m. to like noon the next day, if you can honestly go those 18 hours every single day,
抱歉，把那部分漏掉。我有威士忌滴注，当……是啊，让他说完，戴维。杰森已经长达45分钟没吃东西了。那会被认为是好的吗？就像一次好的跑步？但确实是真的。如果你从晚上6点到第二天中午不吃东西，如果你真的能每天坚持那18个小时，
you're getting yourself into a state where you're... Not only you're getting gorgeously lean, all right? Let's be clear. But you are killing the things that could kill you. You are killing the things that could kill you. So you're going to be gorgeous, but for a very long time. Yes? In principle, yeah, that's the way to do it.
你让自己进入一种状态，你……不仅你变得华丽地瘦，好吗？让我们明确一点。但你正在杀死那些可能杀死你的东西。你正在杀死那些可能杀死你的东西。所以你会变得华丽，但会持续很长时间。是吗？原则上，是啊，那是做它的方法。
And it's not that hard. If you're really starving, you're not doing intermittent fasting correctly. You get used to it after about a week or two anyway. I'm not very good at it. I can only go for one or two meals. Some people go for a week. Oh, look at you. Look at you, though.
而且这并不难。如果你真的饿了，你没有正确地进行间歇性断食。无论如何，大约一两周后你就会习惯它。我不擅长这个。我只能坚持一两顿饭。有些人坚持一周。哦，看看你。看看你，虽然。
You're being very humble. Look at you. Look 12. It is remarkable how young you look. I will say that. Yeah, it's crazy. I'm not talking to you, Sean. No, no, it is.
你表现得很谦虚。看看你。看起来12岁。你看起来如此年轻真是非凡。我会这么说。是啊，太疯狂了。我不是在跟你说话，肖恩。不，不，确实是。
I'm complimenting myself. Sean's looking at a long full-length mirror right now. I bring a hand mirror with me wherever I go. But let me ask you something. So I've never met you. I'm already unbelievably fascinated by everything, but for an idiot like myself, so you are a doctor who specializes in anti-aging philosophies,
我在夸奖我自己。肖恩现在正看着一面长全身镜。我走到哪里都带着一面手镜。但让我问你一件事。所以我从没见过你。我已经对一切都难以置信地着迷了，但对于像我这样的白痴来说，所以你是一位专门研究抗衰老哲学的医生，
science, techniques, whatever this... And Jason mentioned when he was introducing you that you have 35 patents. Like, in what? And what are they and what are they used for? Because I... You know the George Foreman grill? Have you ever seen that?
科学、技术，无论这个……杰森介绍你时提到你有35项专利。就像，在什么方面？它们是什么，它们有什么用？因为我……你知道乔治·福尔曼烤架吗？你见过吗？
Yeah. Oh, shit. That's yours. That's yours. Well, it's just the tilt part on it. Just the part that... It just drips off. It drips off.
是啊。哦，该死。那是你的。那是你的。嗯，只是上面的倾斜部分。只是那部分……它只是滴下来。它滴下来。
Without that, you're going to eat all that fat. But what David did was he put it on an angle. It goes into a tray. It goes into a tray and it drips right off. It's unbelievable. And you'll live longer. That's the YouTube video for it. The tray used to be flat.
没有那个，你会吃掉所有那些脂肪。但戴维做的是他把它放在一个角度。它进入一个托盘。它进入一个托盘，然后直接滴下来。这太不可思议了。而且你会活得更长。那是它的YouTube视频。托盘过去是平的。
I fixed that. Right. It's patent number one. No, but tell me about... Because I'm an idiot. So, so far, intermittent fasting, check. Got that. What else can we do and what are your patents for?
我修复了那个。对。它是专利号一。不，但告诉我关于……因为我是个白痴。所以，到目前为止，间歇性断食，勾选。得到了。我们还能做什么，你的专利是干什么的？
Well, the exercise is real. Olive oil is good. Resveratrol in red wine is one of the molecules we worked on. So, red wine in moderate doses is good. What are moderate doses? Careful. One glass or two, okay? Because I need to tell my sponsor.
嗯，锻炼是真的。橄榄油很好。红酒中的白藜芦醇是我们研究过的分子之一。所以，适量饮用红酒是有好处的。什么是适量？小心。一杯或两杯，好吗？因为我需要告诉我的赞助商。
I've been sober a number of years, but if it's coming from a doctor, I'm just going to say, look, I hate to go over your head on this one, but I want to kind of live a little longer. And I know that you guys frown on the drinking in AA. But yeah, does resveratrol live in anything else other than red wine? Not really.
我已经戒酒好几年了，但如果它是来自医生，我只想说，看，我讨厌在这件事上越过你，但我想要活得长一点。而且我知道你们在AA（戒酒互助会）中不赞成喝酒。但，是啊，白藜芦醇存在于红酒以外的任何东西中吗？没有。
Not in any amounts. Capsule? Sure. You can buy it pure. Yeah. I stick some of that in my yogurt. You can buy it pure. Yeah.
没有多少量。胶囊？当然。你可以买纯的。是啊。我把一些那个放进我的酸奶里。你可以买纯的。是啊。
It's available. You can get it from a reputable supplier. Make sure it's a white or gray powder, not brown. That means it's bad. Not out of the back of a van. No. You don't recommend out of the back of a van. So, are you recommending everybody go get their genes
它有售。你可以从信誉良好的供应商那里买到。确保它是白色或灰色的粉末，而不是棕色的。那意味着它是坏的。不是从货车后面买的。不。你不推荐从货车后面买。所以，你推荐每个人都去检测他们的基因
tested for a hundred bucks or whatever you said. And then from that, it's determined what you should avoid, what you should increase or decrease. And that's your base. And then kind of restructure your life according to those results. Yes, absolutely. That's the way to do it. And it's called optimization.
花一百美元或无论你说多少钱。然后从那里，确定你应该避免什么，你应该增加或减少什么。那是你的基础。然后根据那些结果重构你的生活。是的，绝对。那是做它的方法。它被称为优化。
So, take me for example. I've looked at my genome. I've talked to colleagues. What should I do? I eat this. I should do that. I went from a blood test that said I was 58 and I was actually 48 at the time.
所以，以我为例。我看过我的基因组。我跟同事谈过。我该做什么？我吃这个。我应该做那个。我从一个血液测试中得知我58岁，而我当时实际上是48岁。
Changed my life. Changed my lifestyle. Lost a bit of weight. The right things. And then that blood test, you know, it's a bit of alchemy, but it's still somewhat interesting to do. It came back and I was 31.4. Wow.
改变了我的生活。改变了我的生活方式。减掉了一点体重。做正确的事情。然后那个血液测试，你知道，它有点像炼金术，但做起来仍然有点意思。它回来时我变成了31.4岁。哇。
I think there is a lot you can do very quickly in a matter of months to bring your health way back in terms of health and longevity, I believe. You want to hear about the patents? Yes, I want to hear about the patents. And I also want to hear about diabetes because my husband has diabetes. You know that they took a little bit of brain matter from Jason.
我认为你可以在几个月内做很多事情来在健康和长寿方面让你的健康恢复。你想听听专利吗？是的，我想听听专利。而且我也想听听糖尿病，因为我丈夫有糖尿病。你知道他们从杰森那里取了一点脑组织吗？
They said they had the brain of a three-year-old. Yeah. Did you know about this? Yeah. I got the youth going to the wrong part of it, but I've repointed this stuff. The brain power. I'm trying to age my brain now.
他们说他们有三岁小孩的大脑。是啊。你知道这个吗？是啊。我把青春用在了错误的地方，但我已经重新调整了这些东西。脑力。我现在正试图让我的大脑衰老。
David's writing stuff down. He wrote that down. That's how important that information was. It's all for the deposition, Will. Oh, look at that. Three. Oh, count three. There's something that I want to tell you.
戴维正在写东西。他把它写下来了。那信息有多重要。这都是为了证词，威尔。哦，看看那个。三。哦，数三。有些事我想告诉你。
We, because we think we figure out how to reverse the age of cells, and we've done this, as I said, for the eye of old mice. Yeah. And hopefully in two years we'll have tried this in people with glaucoma, pressure in the eye. We're also now doing an experiment to reverse the age of an old brain. So mice get old after about two years, and they forget things
我们，因为我们认为我们弄清楚了如何逆转细胞的年龄，而且我们已经做到了，正如我所说，针对老鼠的眼睛。是啊。希望在两年内我们会在青光眼、眼压高的患者身上尝试这个。我们现在也在做一个实验来逆转老大脑的年龄。所以小鼠在大约两年后变老，它们忘记了事情
typical like a human would at about age 85. Now we're going to test what happens when you turn the age of the brain back to being young again. Maybe not to three, but let's say to the equivalent of a 20-year-old, do you lose your memories or do you regain lost memories? And we'll know that pretty soon. That's crazy. That's crazy.
典型地就像人类在85岁左右一样。现在我们要测试当你把大脑的年龄变回年轻时会发生什么。也许不是三岁，但假设相当于20岁，你会失去记忆还是会重新获得失去的记忆？我们很快就会知道。那太疯狂了。那太疯狂了。
I don't know. With all your science, I don't know if you're going to be able to fix this old soul. Enlightenment stays intact. Well, rest assured. David, what is the breakthrough that you are most excited to see if you happen to live long enough to experience? The things that you were exposed to, like, you know, is it living
我不知道。用你所有的科学，我不知道你是否能修复这个老灵魂。启蒙保持完整。嗯，请放心。戴维，你最兴奋看到如果碰巧活得足够长能体验到的突破是什么？你接触到的那些东西，就像，你知道，是活着
on the moon or is it, you know, probably in your field, I'll bet you. Yeah, it's probably not living on the moon. Well, you know, I'm trying to, I don't know how old our listener is. Our listener never gets old. Yeah, it's, you know, I'm doing my life's passion. I don't want to do anything else with my life. I would have left a long time ago if I did want to do something else.
在月球上，或者，你知道，可能是在你的领域，我敢打赌。是的，它可能不是生活在月球上。嗯，你知道，我正在尝试，我不知道我们的听众有多大年纪。我们的听众永远不会变老。是的，你知道，我正在从事我毕生的事业。我不想在我的生活中做任何其他事情。如果我想做别的事情，我早就离开了。
So I'm trying to figure out how to reset the body and make it healthy again. And I think we're, we've cracked something here. The fact that we can not just make cells behave like they're young, but actually be young again, reset it. I'm basically back to, you know, 20 year old from an 80 year old in the mouse. Is that because you can start a process somewhere in a cellular area
所以我正在尝试弄清楚如何重置身体并使其再次健康。我认为我们，我们在这里取得了一些突破。事实上，我们不仅能让细胞表现得像年轻时一样，而且能让它们真正恢复年轻，重置它们。在小鼠身上，我基本上让它从80岁回到了20岁。这是因为你可以在细胞区域的某个地方启动一个过程
of the body and that it will sort of, for lack of probably an accurate term, metastasize across the body and make the rest of the body as young as that one spot? Because it would, it strikes me as like, you can't just treat one cell and make that good. They all have to become younger again. And is it sort of self perpetuate? We don't know the answer.
身体的某个部位，然后它会，因为缺乏一个准确的术语，在全身“转移”，让身体的其他部分变得和那个点一样年轻吗？因为这让我觉得，你不能只治疗一个细胞就让它变好。它们都必须再次变年轻。这是一种自我延续吗？我们不知道答案。
In much the same way that it does on the aging side, right? Like all the cells kind of age and make one another age, I suppose. Well, there are certain cells that communicate to other cells. So if you change the age of the brain, it looks like the brain can tell the rest of the body to, to be young again. But I think we're probably going to have to reprogram most of the tissues separately. And we're working on that.
就像它在衰老方面所做的那样，对吧？就像所有的细胞都会衰老，并导致彼此衰老，我想。嗯，有些细胞会与其他细胞交流。所以如果你改变了大脑的年龄，看起来大脑可以告诉身体的其他部分再次变年轻。但我认为我们可能必须分别重新编程大多数组织。我们正在研究这个问题。
What we do is we introduce three very early genes, meaning these are genes that we only have on when we're a fertilized egg and developing in the womb. And they stay off when we become adults. But we find that if we turn these three genes on in a mouse that's old, it resets the clock. It resets the, the genome so that it's, that the cell reads it again. But it's of course not one, not one cell.
我们所做的是引入三个非常早期的基因，这意味着这些基因只有在我们是受精卵并在子宫内发育时才会开启。当我们成年后，它们就会关闭。但我们发现，如果我们在一只老鼠身上开启这三个基因，它就会重置时钟。它重置了基因组，以便细胞再次读取它。但这当然不是一个，不是一个细胞。
We're resetting tens of thousands and eventually billions of cells in the body. But it's a true reset. This isn't just, oh, I'll do a bit of exercise and I'll get a little bit healthy. This would be... Right, right, right. It's not conditioning it. Yeah.
我们正在重置体内成千上万，最终是数十亿的细胞。但这是一种真正的重置。这不仅仅是，哦，我会做点运动，我会变得稍微健康一点。这会是……对，对，对。这不是在调节它。是的。
Well, we, we actually, we built the system so that when these genes get introduced, they're permanent. And we can turn them on just by taking an antibiotic. Doxycycline, for example, you might use that for Lyme disease or something. It's very safe. And so what we do with these mice is we, we genetically modify their eyes. We can damage their eyes or let them get old. And then we just give them a course of three weeks of antibiotics and they
嗯，我们，我们实际上建立了这个系统，以便当这些基因被引入时，它们是永久性的。我们只需服用抗生素就可以开启它们。例如多西环素，你可能会用它来治疗莱姆病之类的。它非常安全。所以我们对这些小鼠所做的是，我们对它们的眼睛进行了基因改造。我们可以损伤它们的眼睛或让它们变老。然后我们只需给它们进行为期三周的抗生素疗程，它们
get the right side back. Imagine that in a human, you re-engineer your body. So you have these three youthful genes and every time you want to fix your body or reset your age, you just take a course of antibiotics for three weeks. Jesus Christ. Would it be similar to how some species can shed skin? And so the old skin goes off and a new skin is right underneath it and it has pushed the old stuff out and it replaces it sort of seamlessly?
就能恢复右侧视力。想象一下在人类身上，你重新设计你的身体。所以你有这三个年轻基因，每次你想修复你的身体或重置你的年龄时，你只需服用三周的抗生素疗程。天哪。这会类似于某些物种蜕皮的方式吗？旧皮脱落，新皮就在下面，它把旧的东西推出来，并以某种方式无缝地替换它？
Yeah. You're onto something. What we think is sort of, there are species that we know can regenerate. So you cut off a lizard's tail, it grows back. What else? You can cut off the finger of a mouse that actually can grow back. Starfish. Starfish.
是的。你抓住了重点。我们认为，有些物种我们知道可以再生。所以你切掉蜥蜴的尾巴，它会长回来。还有什么？你可以切掉老鼠的手指，它实际上可以长回来。海星。海星。
A lot of species regrow. Even a jellyfish, you can take a piece of a jellyfish and it can grow a whole new adult. And we can also clone things. We can clone people probably, but we haven't had permission, but you can clone dogs. Do you think someone's done it? Is there, is there a fair chance that somebody's done it? I don't think so. No?
很多物种可以再生。甚至水母，你可以取下一块水母，它就能长出一个全新的成年个体。我们也可以克隆东西。我们可能可以克隆人，但我们没有得到许可，但你可以克隆狗。你认为有人做过吗？有没有，有没有很大的可能性有人做过？我不这么认为。没有？
Not because if that person was crazy enough to do it, they'd be crazy enough to have a press conference as well. Right, right, right. I do know somebody who cloned their dog. That was wild. Really? They did. Successfully cloned it.
不是因为如果那个人疯狂到去做这件事，他们也会疯狂到去开新闻发布会。对，对，对。我确实认识一个克隆了他们狗的人。那太疯狂了。真的吗？他们确实做了。成功克隆了它。
Yeah. I saw it. Well, you know, my question is this. So you're doing this. This is incredible stuff. And of course, this is like, this is going to shift the conversation of our entire existence, right? And this is getting down to, this is it.
是的。我看到了。嗯，你知道，我的问题是这样的。所以你正在做这个。这是不可思议的事情。当然，这就像，这将改变我们整个存在的对话，对吧？这正触及到，就是这个。
This is the most existential, right? So first of all, you must have, I've spent a bit of time around because of what we do. I've spent some time around some people who are crazy rich, who have all the resources. And the one thing they always talk about, because it's the one thing they can't control is their health and they're getting older. Like it makes them fucking crazy because they've got everything else. They've got billions of dollars. You can only have, you can only fly so many private jets around the world and have so many
这是最存在主义的，对吧？所以首先，你一定，因为我们所做的事情，我花了一些时间在周围。我花了一些时间在一些疯狂富有的人身边，他们拥有所有的资源。他们总是谈论的一件事，因为这是他们无法控制的一件事，那就是他们的健康，而且他们正在变老。这让他们他妈的抓狂，因为他们拥有其他一切。他们有数十亿美元。你只能，你只能在世界各地飞这么多私人飞机，拥有这么多
yachts. But they're like, fuck. The one thing that they want to have more than anything is youth. And they hang around with younger people because they're like vampires, et cetera, et cetera. You must have all these incredible billionaires, these one percenters banging down your door. Do you not? You're saying, hurry up, hurry up. Can you say?
游艇。但他们就像，该死。他们最想要的一件事就是青春。他们和年轻人混在一起，因为他们像吸血鬼，等等，等等。你一定有所有这些不可思议的亿万富翁，这些百分之一的人在敲你的门。不是吗？你在说，快点，快点。你能说吗？
I want elasticity on my skin again. Yeah. I know a fair number of people. Yeah. I bet. Put it that way. I bet. Also, can I jump line in front of them?
我想让我的皮肤再次有弹性。是的。我认识相当多的人。是的。我敢打赌。这么说吧。我敢打赌。另外，我可以插队排在他们前面吗？
A. Because I'm a cool guy. They're all so fucking boring and I'm a lot more fun to hang out with. I guarantee you, and I'm not going to name names on the air. Can you put some jet hours on that? I can't add jet hours, but I will say this. I can add a lot of laughs and that plane, it sucks if you're not having a laugh. A.
A. 因为我是个酷家伙。他们都他妈的太无聊了，和我在一起玩要有趣得多。我向你保证，我不会在广播里点名。你能在上面加一些喷气机时间吗？我不能增加喷气机时间，但我会说这个。我可以增加很多笑声，如果你没有笑声，那架飞机就很糟糕。A.
And B, let me have it before Bateman because I want to start getting young. I'm not saying he doesn't get to have any of the magic pills. I want him to have it, but let me have it like a week before. What is your ultimate dream for their human race? Do you wish there was a pill that everybody could take? I mean, we've been told it's all about diet and exercise our whole lives. And of course, that's the answer for everything and everybody knows that answer. It's just up to you whether you implement that or not into your life.
还有B，让我在贝特曼之前得到它，因为我想开始变年轻。我不是说他不能拥有任何神奇的药丸。我希望他拥有它，但让我比他早一周得到它。你对人类的终极梦想是什么？你希望有一种每个人都能服用的药丸吗？我的意思是，我们一生都被告知这完全取决于饮食和运动。当然，那是对每个人和所有问题的答案。这取决于你是否在你的生活中实施它。
But to you, what is the ultimate goal? Yeah, it's to have a pill or a combination of pills that truly resets the age of the body. And I know we've been working on this as species for the last probably half a million, million years. But nobody's had this technology. No one's been able to take a blind mouse and reset the age of the eye and make it see again. So that's why I say it's like the Wright Brothers, right? The Wright Brothers, everyone said, come on, you can't fly. Humans were never meant to fly.
但对你来说，终极目标是什么？是的，就是拥有一种药丸或药丸组合，真正重置身体的年龄。我知道我们作为物种在过去大概五十万、一百万年里一直在研究这个问题。但没有人拥有这种技术。没有人能够让一只失明的老鼠重置眼睛的年龄并让它再次看见。这就是为什么我说这就像莱特兄弟，对吧？莱特兄弟，每个人都说，得了吧，你不能飞。人类注定不能飞。
But they did it and suddenly the world changed. And I truly believe that we're at that point now with aging. Right, right. And has anybody ever discussed with you about the population control thing about like, I imagine, if you're in the business of prolonging people's lives, I'm sure there are people not loving that because you say the world is already overpopulated. And why are we trying to interrupt nature's course of resetting itself? And there's a great deal of money to be made on people that are not in good health.
但他们做到了，世界突然改变了。我真心相信我们现在在衰老方面也处于那个阶段。对，对。有没有人跟你讨论过关于人口控制的事情，比如，我想，如果你从事延长人们寿命的行业，我相信有些人不喜欢这样，因为你说世界已经人口过剩了。为什么我们要试图打断自然重置的过程？而且在那些健康状况不佳的人身上可以赚很多钱。
This comes up a lot and I've written about it. There are two sides to it. There are certain people who will live longer that we probably don't want to live longer. That's one of the downsides. But there's also, you look at history. I like to look at history and use it to predict the future. You know, when people were dying in their 40s and 50s and women were dying childbirth, the world had a lot fewer people.
这经常被提起，我也写过关于它的文章。它有两个方面。有些人会活得更长，我们可能不希望他们活得更长。这是缺点之一。但也有，你看看历史。我喜欢看历史并用它来预测未来。你知道，当人们在40多岁和50多岁时死去，妇女死于分娩时，世界的人口要少得多。
But was that a better world? And I'm of the belief that humans can innovate their way around anything. And actually, if you do the math, if we were to stop everybody dying right now, we wouldn't get hugely overpopulated, not very quickly anyway. And in Europe and increasingly in the US, we're actually slowing down our population growth to the point of being negative. And so it'll be replacement. We'll probably top out at about 11 billion on the planet.
但那是一个更好的世界吗？我相信人类可以通过创新来解决任何问题。事实上，如果你算一下，如果我们现在停止所有人的死亡，我们也不会变得人口过剩，至少不会很快。在欧洲和越来越多的美国，我们实际上正在减缓人口增长，直到负增长。所以这将是更替。我们可能会在地球上达到约110亿的峰值。
And then we'll be hopefully steady state with people living 110, 120, eventually longer than that. When do you think that'll be that people will commonly live past 100? Well, so my colleagues often don't like it when I say these things because they want it all to be based in fact, whereas I'm trying to predict the future. It's always dangerous. I would say within our lifetime, there will be medicines available to slow aging and some that will reverse it. But the question also becomes great.
然后我们希望会处于稳定状态，人们活到110岁、120岁，最终比那更长。你认为人们普遍活过100岁会是什么时候？嗯，所以我的同事们通常不喜欢我这么说，因为他们希望这一切都基于事实，而我正在尝试预测未来。这总是很危险的。我会说在我们的有生之年，将会有药物可以减缓衰老，有些可以逆转它。但问题也变成了太好了。
So you live to be 103, but what is your life like? What is your body like? Yeah, the quality of life in that last decade. Well, this is the key. This is the key question. And what we know from these animal studies, whether they're in, I've mentioned mice, but we've done a lot of people done monkey studies, dog studies, and even studies with pills in humans.
所以你活到了103岁，但你的生活是什么样的？你的身体是什么样的？是的，最后十年的生活质量。嗯，这是关键。这是关键问题。我们从这些动物研究中知道，无论它们是在，我提到了小鼠，但我们已经做了很多人做了猴子研究、狗研究，甚至在人类身上进行了药丸研究。
We know that these interventions we call them that slow down aging. They slow down aging in the whole body. So it's not like a heart medicine that just keeps your heart healthy, but your brain gets old. It's very different. So what you get are these animals that live a lot better and healthier, they're vibrant, and then they die much quicker. Look at humans that live over 100.
我们知道这些我们称之为减缓衰老的干预措施。它们减缓了整个身体的衰老。所以它不像心脏药物那样只是保持你的心脏健康，但你的大脑却变老了。它非常不同。所以你得到的是这些动物活得更好、更健康，它们充满活力，然后它们死得更快。看看活过100岁的人。
They cost about a third of the healthcare costs of someone who gets sick before 100. So it's also a huge cost saving as well. And these people are productive helping with grandkids, going back to work. It's a huge burden to the economy as well. Right. And so, but that's interesting. You say that people actually, you might live longer, but your period of death is sort of truncated, right?
他们的医疗成本大约是那些在100岁之前生病的人的三分之一。所以这也是巨大的成本节约。而且这些人很有生产力，帮助照顾孙辈，重返工作岗位。这对经济来说也是一个巨大的负担。对。所以，但这很有趣。你说人们实际上，你可能会活得更长，但你的死亡期被缩短了，对吧？
So you don't die in some protracted, miserable sort of, these machines are keeping you alive. We call that modern medicine, unfortunately. Yeah. That's what we've been trying to do, which is treat one disease at a time, push the patient out the door. If they come back with something else, treat that and repeat until failure. And that's not the way to do it.
所以你不会死于某种漫长、悲惨的，这些机器让你活着。我们称之为现代医学，不幸的是。是的。这就是我们一直试图做的，即一次治疗一种疾病，把病人推出门外。如果他们带着别的东西回来，治疗那个，然后重复直到失败。这不是解决办法。
It's money. Yeah. Right. Wow. Yeah. Because, you know, also I always hear about Alzheimer's, diabetes, you know, heart conditions, you know, everybody, I always hear about, you know, they're three to five years away.
这是钱。是的。对。哇。是的。因为，你知道，我也总是听说阿尔茨海默病、糖尿病、你知道，心脏病，你知道，每个人，我总是听说，你知道，他们离三到五年。
They're three to five years away of getting a vaccine or a cure or something, some kind of something. And I never see any results of those, you know, like it's just an ongoing thing. It's very frustrating. Obviously it's all financially based. And if we cure something, then there's no money in it anymore. And, but what do you say to that?
他们离获得疫苗或治愈方法或某种东西还有三到五年。但我从来没有看到任何结果，你知道，就像这是一件正在进行的事情。这非常令人沮丧。显然这一切都是基于经济的。如果我们治愈了什么，那么它就没钱可赚了。而且，但你对此怎么说？
Because my mom died from Alzheimer's. My husband has diabetes. Like I know all of these people who have all these issues that we just keep hearing good news is on the horizon and we never get it. Well, we do get it, but it's usually it's small increments. There's never, oh, suddenly we can cure Alzheimer's. That doesn't happen. And the problem really is that it's easy to say it's in five years,
因为我妈妈死于阿尔茨海默病。我丈夫有糖尿病。就像我认识所有这些有所有这些问题的人，我们只是不断听到好消息即将到来，但我们从未得到它。嗯，我们确实得到了它，但通常是小幅度的。从来没有，哦，突然我们可以治愈阿尔茨海默病。那不会发生。真正的问题是，说五年内实现很容易，
but because now I've lived it, I've started a number of biotech companies. It's way harder than most people think. It's at least 10 years from start to finish and about a billion dollars, which is very hard, of course. To do a trial, to do a series of trials. Yeah, to get a drug on the market and most drugs fail and 90% of them fail. So it's easy to say five years, it's much harder to do. But if you look at the long arc of history, we are making progress.
但因为我现在已经经历了它，我已经创办了多家生物技术公司。这比大多数人想象的要难得多。从开始到结束至少需要10年，大约十亿美元，当然这非常困难。进行试验，进行一系列试验。是的，让药物上市，大多数药物失败，90%的药物失败。所以说五年很容易，做起来要难得多。但如果你看看历史的长河，我们正在取得进展。
People are not suffering like they did even 10 years ago, especially in the cancer field, huge breakthroughs there. But for aging, not so much. Sean, I want to quickly tell you about the diabetes area. There are some really good diabetes drugs. I think we have a much better handle on that disease. Type 2 diabetes, not so much one. Is that what you're referring to?
人们不像10年前那样受苦了，特别是在癌症领域，那里有巨大的突破。但对于衰老，没那么多。肖恩，我想快速告诉你关于糖尿病领域的事情。有一些非常好的糖尿病药物。我认为我们对那种疾病有了更好的掌握。2型糖尿病，1型没那么多。你指的是那个吗？
Type 1, yeah. The age associated. Oh, type 1, yeah. That one's harder. Yeah, that's not easy because there's all sorts of cells you have to replace. But didn't they have a big breakthrough in type 1 diabetes about 5, 10 years ago? Well, the stem cell replacement seems to be going well. Yeah, yeah.
1型，是的。与年龄相关的。哦，1型，是的。那个更难。是的，那不容易，因为有各种各样的细胞你需要替换。但他们在大约5、10年前在1型糖尿病方面没有取得重大突破吗？嗯，干细胞替换似乎进展顺利。是的，是的。
But that's really hard. Is stem cells similar to CRISPR? Is that the same thing? Well, it can be together. You can go in and change the cells in your body. Or you can take your stem cells out, fix those and put them back in. And that's actually done. For instance, sickle cell anemia has been cured now by taking out the blood stem cells
但这真的很难。干细胞类似于CRISPR吗？那是同一回事吗？嗯，它们可以结合在一起。你可以进去改变你体内的细胞。或者你可以取出你的干细胞，修复它们，然后放回去。这实际上已经完成了。例如，镰状细胞性贫血现在已经通过取出血液干细胞治愈了
and fixing those and putting them back in. Wow. Let me ask you something that might be outside of your specialty. It's just something I've always been fascinated by. Maybe you can tell me something if you know about it. Is the actual science of the brain that I'm sure is sending out all these messages to these cells about how to age and how not to age and whatnot. Some of the limitations come in progress from still not truly understanding
并修复它们，然后放回去。哇。让我问你一个可能超出你专业领域的问题。这只是我一直着迷的事情。也许如果你知道的话，你可以告诉我一些事情。是大脑的实际科学，我相信它正在向这些细胞发送所有关于如何衰老以及如何不衰老等等的信息。一些局限性来自于仍然没有真正理解
how the brain works and what the brain does as far as sending out messages. Like what is the equation of a thought? Literally how one gets an idea and like how do you, like what does that look like? That's not zeros and ones and it's not proteins. It's like, does it live in that? Are we getting closer to figuring out how the brain actually creates thinking and what that looks like from an equation standpoint? We are actually.
大脑是如何工作的，以及大脑在发送信息方面做了什么。比如思想的方程式是什么？字面上一个人是如何产生想法的，比如你怎么，比如那看起来像什么？那不是零和一，也不是蛋白质。就像，它生活在那个里面吗？我们是否越来越接近弄清楚大脑实际上是如何创造思维的，以及从方程式的角度来看那是什么样子的？我们确实是。
There are some people who are able to model the brain and the problem has been a reductionist attitudes until recently, meaning you go into the brain, you put a neuron in the dish and you look at how the neuron works. That's great, but because you've got a trillion cells in your brain, there's emergent properties as they say. One nerve is not going to be a brain, two nerves isn't going to be a brain, but a trillion will be.
有些人能够模拟大脑，问题直到最近都是还原论的态度，这意味着你进入大脑，把一个神经元放在培养皿里，你观察神经元是如何工作的。那很好，但因为你的大脑里有一万亿个细胞，正如他们所说，有涌现属性。一个神经不会是一个大脑，两个神经不会是一个大脑，但一万亿个会是。
What people are discovering actually is similar to a computer. If you look at one transistor, it's not going to tell you how a computer works, but you have to look at the whole thing. Same with the brain. There's a guy called Henry Mark, who's a really controversial figure in Europe, but he managed to model a mouse brain and now he's done a human brain. He did it because typical neural nets are looking at binary, basically computer code. He said, let's get away from binary, which is how big companies like Facebook and Google do it.
人们实际上发现的类似于计算机。如果你看一个晶体管，它不会告诉你计算机是如何工作的，但你必须看整个东西。大脑也是如此。有一个叫亨利·马克的人，他在欧洲是一个非常有争议的人物，但他成功地模拟了小鼠大脑，现在他已经完成了人类大脑。他这样做是因为典型的神经网络正在看二进制，基本上是计算机代码。他说，让我们远离二进制，这就是像Facebook和谷歌这样的大公司所做的方式。
He said, let's figure out how to model a nerve cell and then put a trillion of those together, because nerve cells, they work rather than just on and off like a computer. It's more like a record player or a cassette tape. They have what's called analog information. Long story short, when he built this brain in the computer, it behaved in ways that he could never have predicted with waves of thought going through the system. So I think we're getting close, but you need the trillions upon trillions of little individual machines put together to make that happen.
他说，让我们弄清楚如何模拟一个神经细胞，然后把一万亿个放在一起，因为神经细胞，它们的工作方式不仅仅像计算机那样开和关。它更像唱片机或盒式磁带。它们有所谓的模拟信息。长话短说，当他在计算机中构建这个大脑时，它的行为方式是他无法预测的，系统中有思想的波浪穿过。所以我认为我们越来越接近了，但你需要数万亿又数万亿的小型独立机器放在一起才能实现这一点。
Wow. So we're all going to be cyborgs in about 2,000 years. Well, yes, but I don't believe that you can download your brain easily. That to me is much harder than solving aging. Yes. Right. All right. Do you ever see a day when this kind of theory has been tossed around in science fiction,
哇。所以我们大约2000年后都会成为半机械人。嗯，是的，但我认为你不能轻易下载你的大脑。对我来说，这比解决衰老要难得多。是的。对。好吧。你有没有见过有一天这种理论在科幻小说中被抛来抛去，
where at a very young age, you can download information into the human brain so that a whole set of encyclopedias are all of Google into your brain. Like in the matrix when I learned how to fly the helicopter. Well, not so much that. What do you mean? Not so much that. But so that just... Do you mean about flying helicopters?
在很小的时候，你可以把信息下载到人脑中，这样整套百科全书或所有谷歌都在你的大脑里。就像在《黑客帝国》里我学会了如何驾驶直升机。嗯，没那么多。你是什么意思？没那么多。但为了只是……你是说关于驾驶直升机？
Do you mean about flying helicopters? Do you mean about I go to sleep and I... Can you download information? I go to sleep and I wake up and I know how to speak French. Carianne Moss in the matrix? If I wake up, I'm Carianne the helicopter. Now I look like Carianne Moss in the morning. Now everybody's going to be a bunch of Carianne Mosses wearing tight leather.
你是说关于驾驶直升机？你是说关于我睡觉然后我……你能下载信息吗？我睡觉然后我醒来，我知道怎么说法语。凯瑞-安·莫斯在《黑客帝国》里？如果我醒来，我是直升机的凯瑞-安。现在我早上看起来像凯瑞-安·莫斯。现在每个人都会是一群穿着紧身皮衣的凯瑞-安·莫斯。
Sean, what are you getting at? David, can that work? Do you know that Sean, if you open up a cross-section of Sean's brain, it's like a mouse on a treadmill in the Benny Hill theme song playing. No, that's why I'm exhausted all the time. David, how did you get attracted to studying about aging specifically? Was it kind of just a process of what you became interested in medical school, or was it something when you were a kid,
肖恩，你想说什么？大卫，那行得通吗？你知道肖恩，如果你打开肖恩大脑的横截面，就像本尼·希尔主题曲播放时跑步机上的老鼠。不，这就是我一直精疲力竭的原因。大卫，你是怎么被吸引去专门研究衰老的？这只是你在医学院变得感兴趣的过程，还是当你还是个孩子时，
you lost a relative at too young an age? Yeah, I don't need therapy. Probably this is my therapy. There was a moment when my grandmother, who helped raise me, she was very brutal. She grew up in World War II and she just said everything that was truthful. So like most kids, I said, oh, grandma, will you always be around to protect me?
你失去了一位太年轻的亲戚？是的，我不需要治疗。这可能是我的治疗。有一个时刻，我的祖母，她帮我抚养长大，她非常残酷。她在二战中长大，她只是说了所有真实的话。所以像大多数孩子一样，我说，哦，奶奶，你会一直在我身边保护我吗？
And I was about three and a half, four years old. And she said, nope, I'm going to die, and then you'll be alone. And I was just like, whoa. Mortality. And we all go through that, but that I think set me in motion. But I've always liked pulling things apart, machines, cocoons, spiders, that kind of stuff. And I figured why not figure out the hardest problem that we haven't solved,
那时我大约三岁半，四岁。她说，不，我要死了，然后你就会孤单一人。我当时就像，哇。死亡。我们都经历过那个，但我认为那让我开始行动。但我一直喜欢拆解东西，机器、茧、蜘蛛，那种东西。我想为什么不弄清楚我们还没有解决的最难的问题，
which I thought was aging. And you're feeling bullish that you will see the fruits of your labor before, do you expect to benefit from the science that you are navigating now when it comes your time to slow down a bit? Well, I feel like I'm already benefiting. Whenever I get something that's convincing and safe, I apply it. And then my family, who's a bunch of scientists also applies it. My father's 80 now and out doing his peers.
我认为那是衰老。你是否感到乐观，认为你会在之前看到你劳动的成果，当你该慢下来一点时，你期望从你现在正在导航的科学中受益吗？嗯，我觉得我已经受益了。每当我得到一些令人信服且安全的东西时，我就应用它。然后我的家人，他们也是一群科学家，也应用它。我父亲现在80岁了，表现超过了他的同龄人。
What about your kids? So are you applying this stuff to your kid's lifestyle? Are they taking it on? Are they like going with their friends and their friends? Are they like, okay, let's grab a big Mac. And they're like, no way. I'm just going to eat this leaf. Why?
你的孩子呢？所以你正在把这些东西应用到你孩子的生活方式中吗？他们正在接受它吗？他们像和他们的朋友以及他们的朋友一起去吗？他们像，好吧，让我们去吃个巨无霸。而他们说，没门。我只是要吃这片叶子。为什么？
Because I'm going to live to be three million and you're going to die next week. Are they? No, I think they're the opposite. They're like, I'll screw what dad says. I'm going to do the opposite. Is that right? Of course. We're a very normal family.
因为我要活到三百万岁，而你下周就会死。他们是吗？不，我认为他们正好相反。他们就像，去他妈的爸爸说的。我要做相反的事。是这样吗？当然。我们是一个非常正常的家庭。
Yeah. Tell me about, I'm sorry to keep going back to this, but tell me about your patents or your favorite two out of your 800. Well, they're mixed. What I do in my lab is I bring together people that have very different views and skills from computer technicians to people can read a genome on a little muesli bar type of thing, health bar. So what we do, I have about 20 or so people at Harvard and we don't work on what's the
是的。告诉我关于，我很抱歉一直回到这个问题，但告诉我关于你的专利或你800个专利中最喜欢的两个。嗯，它们是混合的。我在实验室里所做的是，我把有非常不同观点和技能的人聚集在一起，从计算机技术人员到可以在某种麦片棒、健康棒上阅读基因组的人。所以我们所做的，我在哈佛大约有20个人，我们不研究从我们现在所处的位置
next thing to discover from where we are. We just sit around saying what's a really good question to answer. And once you have a good question, then we figure out how to answer it. So one of them, which you might be surprised about, well, actually probably half of them have nothing to do with aging. One interesting one was we were trying to figure out how to speed the transmission of genetic data across the internet. And we came up with the idea that instead of having binary code, which is zeros and ones,
接下来要发现什么。我们只是坐在一起说，什么是一个真正好的问题来回答。一旦你有一个好问题，然后我们就弄清楚如何回答它。所以其中一个，你可能会感到惊讶，嗯，实际上可能有一半与衰老无关。一个有趣的是，我们试图弄清楚如何加快遗传数据在互联网上的传输。我们想出了一个主意，与其使用二进制代码，也就是零和一，
we could use four letters, which is what DNA is based on. So we used what's called base four math. I mean, what happened, it's an interesting story. I'll be very quick. That led to us developing little mini supercomputers in my office on my desk, which eventually moved into my garage, which eventually moved into a company. And then we used that knowledge and better math and algorithms to build what's called a graph, a mathematical graph of the human genome.
我们可以使用四个字母，这就是DNA的基础。所以我们使用了所谓的四进制数学。我的意思是，发生了什么，这是一个有趣的故事。我会很快。这导致我们开发了放在我办公室桌子上的小型超级计算机，最终搬到了我的车库，最终搬到了一家公司。然后我们利用这些知识和更好的数学和算法来构建所谓的图，人类基因组的数学图。
Then we used that same technology to build a graph of all known pathogens in the world, including now COVID or coronavirus too. And now it can take anyone's blood at this company and take out the human DNA because we have technology to do that. It's related to CRISPR. Instead of changing genes, we use it as a fishing rod and pull out all the human DNA. What's left behind are the pathogens, the viruses, the fungi, the bacteria. Then we'd read all that DNA, pump it into our supercomputer, and it says, oh, you have
然后我们利用同样的技术构建了世界上所有已知病原体的图，包括现在的COVID或冠状病毒2。现在这家公司可以取任何人的血液，取出人类DNA，因为我们有技术这样做。它与CRISPR有关。与其改变基因，我们把它当作钓鱼竿，把所有的人类DNA拉出来。留下的是病原体、病毒、真菌、细菌。然后我们读取所有这些DNA，泵入我们的超级计算机，它说，哦，你有
the flu. Don't worry, you don't have COVID-19. And that's actually one of the ones I'm most proud of because my daughter, our daughter, Natalie, a middle daughter, she had Lyme disease. And the test for Lyme disease was taking a week and she was losing her eyesight. And I said, we've got to have a better way to do this. So we invented that. Wow.
流感。别担心，你没有COVID-19。这实际上是我最引以为豪的之一，因为我的女儿，我们的女儿，娜塔莉，中间的女儿，她得了莱姆病。莱姆病的测试需要一周时间，她正在失去视力。我说，我们必须有一种更好的方法来做这件事。所以我们发明了那个。哇。
Wow. This is crazy. That story, I literally, I did the same thing. I did the exact, all of that. You forgot to patent it. All of that stuff other than the daughter part. You just didn't take the stuff to patent it. But inventing this supercomputer with my buddies and moving it into my garage and then doing
哇。这太疯狂了。那个故事，我字面上，我做了同样的事情。我做了确切的，所有这一切。你忘了申请专利。除了女儿部分之外的所有东西。你只是没有采取申请专利的东西。但我与我的伙伴们发明了这台超级计算机，并把它搬进我的车库，然后做
taking out the, and leaving just the fungi and all of it. And I'm like, I'm thinking, nobody's going to relate to this. And then I met David and it's incredible because I can't tell these two idiots. They don't know, but you and I are speaking a language because we're both inventing. So David, if I go out and I get my blood taken and do all this gene research and stuff like that, can I expect to get basically a prognosis, a menu of, okay, Jason, you are susceptible to dying from heart disease, but not cancer or leukemia, not Alzheimer's, et cetera, et cetera.
取出，只留下真菌和所有这一切。我想，没有人会与此产生共鸣。然后我遇到了大卫，这太不可思议了，因为我不能告诉这两个白痴。他们不知道，但你和我正在说一种语言，因为我们都在发明。所以大卫，如果我出去做血液检查并做所有这些基因研究之类的东西，我可以期望得到基本上一个预后，一个菜单，好吧，杰森，你容易死于心脏病，但不是癌症或白血病，不是阿尔茨海默病，等等，等等。
So then you can be a little bit more sort of focused on the preventive measures that you might take specifically to those. Yeah. Oh, absolutely. Without that, you're flying blind. It's like driving a car without a dashboard. Who would do that? Right.
所以你可以更专注于你可能采取的针对这些的具体预防措施。是的。哦，绝对。没有那个，你就像盲人摸象。这就像开一辆没有仪表盘的车。谁会那样做？对。
So I'm very much driven by data and a lot of people are scared by what they might learn. You learn interesting and important things. So one of the things is it's a learning lesson. My kids all have their genome. Actually, I got my grandmother's genome done. She was about 85 and I gave her a tube to spit in. She was thinking worst present ever. Do you have the receipt?
所以我非常受数据驱动，很多人被他们可能学到的东西吓坏了。你学到了有趣且重要的事情。所以其中一件事是一个学习的教训。我的孩子们都有他们的基因组。实际上，我做了我祖母的基因组。她大约85岁，我给了她一个管子让她吐口水。她当时想这是有史以来最糟糕的礼物。你有收据吗？
Yeah, right, right. Can we give this back? So we do our genome because it does tell us what we should try to avoid. So I've got genes for type 2 diabetes and obesity. So I changed my lifestyle to avoid that. Same with my father. It's actually quite accurate in our experience. My father had genes or variant of a gene for macular degeneration.
是的，对，对。我们可以退货吗？所以我们做我们的基因组，因为它确实告诉我们应该尽量避免什么。所以我有了2型糖尿病和肥胖的基因。所以我改变了我的生活方式来避免这种情况。我父亲也是。在我们的经验中，它实际上相当准确。我父亲有黄斑变性的基因或基因变体。
And that's starting to show up. So I highly recommend it. Now, we don't know everything, of course, because we're still learning, but it's getting better and better each year as we learn what these variations lead to. And for instance, my wife, her mother has this bowel disease and she learned, my wife learned that she had the same susceptibility genes when she did the test. So she changed her whole life. She actually, she left work.
那开始显现了。所以我强烈推荐它。现在，我们当然不知道一切，因为我们还在学习，但随着我们了解这些变异导致什么，它变得越来越好。例如，我的妻子，她的母亲有这种肠道疾病，她了解到，我的妻子在做测试时了解到她有同样的易感基因。所以她改变了她的整个生活。她实际上，她离开了工作。
She started eating differently. And so those kind of things can really make a difference. Got it. So in addition to perhaps this intermittent fasting, exercise, diet, I think you mentioned that there's also some supplements, and maybe that's not the right term, that you can take that can augment this, amplify that work. Is that true?
她开始吃得不同。所以这些事情真的可以有所作为。明白了。所以除了这种间歇性禁食、运动、饮食之外，我想你提到还有一些补充剂，也许那不是正确的术语，你可以服用这些补充剂来增强，放大这项工作。那是真的吗？
Yeah, it is. I have to be careful because I'm not a doctor and also I'm in Harvard Medical School, that frowns on supplements. They like pharmaceuticals that are proven to work. But there's this middle ground where there are these safe, seemingly safe supplements that probably won't hurt you, that have a chance of helping you in the long run. Some of which I take, not a bunch.
是的，确实。我必须小心，因为我不是医生，而且我在哈佛医学院，那不赞成补充剂。他们喜欢被证明有效的药物。但有一个中间地带，有一些安全的、看起来安全的补充剂，可能不会伤害你，长期来看有机会帮助你。其中一些我服用，不是很多。
And someone who's curious could find these things out by researching you online or reading one of your books or... How does Jason find out what to take? Yeah, I'm trying to get some free medical advice. No one's listening, David. Just whisper it. So my book, the book that came out a few months ago is called Lyspan, page 304, turn to that, and it's the cheat sheet. But try to read the other parts.
而一个好奇的人可以通过在线研究你或阅读你的书之一来找出这些东西……杰森怎么找出该服用什么？是的，我正在尝试获得一些免费的医疗建议。没有人听，大卫。只是小声说出来。所以我的书，几个月前出的那本书叫《寿命》，第304页，翻到那一页，那是小抄。但试着读读其他部分。
It's also a little bit interesting. Jason, a book is, imagine TV, but it's broken into pages. Like chapters. Left to right, top to bottom. Yes. Got it. Yeah. Actually, I put pictures in the book.
这也有一点意思。杰森，书是，想象电视，但它被分成页。像章节。从左到右，从上到下。是的。明白了。是的。实际上，我在书里放了图片。
What? Oh, this is nice. Can I color those? Pop up? Yeah. And as far as the genes go, when you suggested we all get our genome tested or revealed, whatever, that we could just ask our own doctors and they would have the information on how to do that? Not really.
什么？哦，这很好。我可以给它们涂色吗？弹出式？是的。至于基因，当你建议我们都去测试或揭示我们的基因组时，无论什么，我们可以直接问我们自己的医生，他们会有关于如何做这件事的信息吗？并不是真的。
You just go direct to the companies and they send you a kit. Oh, so one of those. Right, right, right. Can I come to the lab, David? I guess that's what we're all getting at. We just want to come to the lab. You strap me to a table, take all my blood, strip my gene, whatever it is. Take it all.
你直接去找公司，他们会寄给你一个套件。哦，所以是其中之一。对，对，对。我可以去实验室吗，大卫？我想这就是我们都在说的。我们只是想去实验室。你把我绑在桌子上，抽我所有的血，剥离我的基因，无论它是什么。全部拿走。
Take my genes off. No, he's talking about a genome. Genome. Will. My friend. Genome. I just checked. I had somebody go out and check my genome on the yard.
把我的基因拿走。不，他在谈论基因组。基因组。威尔。我的朋友。基因组。我刚查过。我让人出去查了我在院子里的基因组。
He's Belgian. He's got a little red hat. That's a no. No, no, no. I think he's Belgian. My friend, my friend, Kevin Deeland thought 23 and me was a dating site. Anyway, very good. So, but can we get to Sean's point, like what is the best course of action?
他是比利时人。他戴着一顶小红帽。那是不。不，不，不。我想他是比利时人。我的朋友，我的朋友，凯文·迪兰以为23 and Me是一个约会网站。总之，非常好。所以，但我们可以谈谈肖恩的观点吗，比如最好的行动方案是什么？
I guess, so it's to get with one of these companies. I think people are worried now because they feel like if they send their DNA into 23 and me, they're going to, you know, next week, their uncle is going to be found out to be, you know, a mass murderer, which seems to happen a lot. Yeah. Which is kind of cool, I got to say. There is that downside. You can ask the companies to keep it totally anonymous.
我想，所以是和这些公司之一合作。我想人们现在很担心，因为他们觉得如果他们把他们的DNA寄给23 and Me，他们会，你知道，下周，他们的叔叔会被发现是，你知道，一个大规模杀人犯，这似乎经常发生。是的。这很酷，我必须说。确实有那个缺点。你可以要求公司保持完全匿名。
I think that's the best way. That's what I did. But yeah, it's a slight risk. I'm not actually sure if there is a company that deletes the data once it's done. Yeah. That would be good. But you can come to the lab. You know, the problem is it can't have, you know, 10,000 or 100,000 people listening here,
我认为那是最好的方式。我就是那样做的。但是的，这是一个轻微的风险。我实际上不确定是否有一家公司在完成后删除数据。是的。那会很好。但你可以来实验室。你知道，问题是不能有，你知道，1万或10万人在听这里，
maybe more come to my lab. But if you guys want to come, I can definitely do some tests and we can film that if you want and put you in the middle and see how you do. Wow. I love that. Very special to partner. Yeah. We do that around sweeps.
也许更多人来我的实验室。但如果你们想来，我绝对可以做一些测试，如果我们愿意，我们可以拍摄那个，把你放在中间，看看你做得怎么样。哇。我喜欢那个。非常特别的合作伙伴。是的。我们在扫荡期间做那个。
Do we have sweeps in podcasting? Sure. We'll create it. David, we have taken a lot of your time. I can't thank you enough. I thought we were going to get all the way through it without anybody making a jeans joke. And then I did it.
我们在播客中有扫荡吗？当然。我们会创造它。大卫，我们占用了你很多时间。我怎么感谢你都不为过。我以为我们会在没有人开基因玩笑的情况下完成它。然后我做了。
But that was too low even for me. That fruit was too low hanging. I could hear you guys restraining yourselves out of respect. But so I apologize for that. But thank you very, very much for joining us and making us a little less on smart today with your stuff. It is fascinating. I love this.
但这对我来说也太低了。那果子挂得太低了。我能听到你们出于尊重在克制自己。但我为此道歉。但非常非常感谢你加入我们，并用你的东西让我们今天变得不那么聪明。这太迷人了。我喜欢这个。
I'm going to check out your book and read more about you. It's so fascinating. David, what's your book called again? Lifespan. Lifespan. Yeah. Why we age and why we don't have to. Lifespan.
我要去看看你的书，多读读关于你的东西。这太迷人了。大卫，你的书叫什么名字？《寿命》。《寿命》。是的。为什么我们衰老以及为什么我们不必衰老。《寿命》。
I love it. I love it. I can't even remember the name of the book. I'm such a dummy. That's an old brain of yours. I can't wait. Thank you. Thanks, David.
我喜欢它。我喜欢它。我甚至记不住书的名字。我真是个笨蛋。那是你的老大脑。我等不及了。谢谢。谢谢，大卫。
I need to get there. I can't wait for you to give me. Grow me a new brain. It's going to be great. Try being hungry a little bit, Will. For anything. Yeah. What's hungry?
我需要到那里。我等不及你给我了。给我长个新大脑。那会很棒的。试着饿一点，威尔。为了任何事情。是的。什么是饿？
David. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you guys. It's been fun. Thank you, my friend. All right.
大卫。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢你们。这很有趣。谢谢你，我的朋友。好吧。
Go ahead. Cheers. Bye. So I could have talked to him for nine hours. Isn't it pretty interesting that, you know, you cannot catch any of these diseases that kill you. They're all in us. All of these diseases.
去吧。干杯。再见。所以我可以和他谈九个小时。你不觉得很有趣吗，你知道，你不能感染任何这些杀死你的疾病。它们都在我们体内。所有这些疾病。
They're all in us. And if you behave a certain way, you will turn those things on and they will kill you. You know what, you know what disease always gets turned on me is the horn dog disease. That always gets turned on. So my thing is like, if there's all of this information about all this anti-aging stuff that works, how is this not bigger news? Like how do we make this?
它们都在我们体内。如果你表现得某种方式，你就会开启那些东西，它们就会杀死你。你知道吗，你知道什么疾病总是被开启在我身上，是好色病。那总是被开启。所以我的想法是，如果关于所有这些抗衰老的东西有这么多信息，为什么这不是更大的新闻？就像我们怎么让这个……
You know, I was, I was going to mention that to him and I thought, well, that might be offensive. Yeah. Exactly. It's like, like what, what are they holding back? Why is this not leading the national news? I think the problem is that people are so wrapped up. As you know, people are just busy with their, just other shit going on and they just go
你知道，我，我本来要向他提到这一点，我想，那可能会冒犯。是的。正是。就像，就像什么，他们在隐瞒什么？为什么这没有成为全国新闻的头条？我认为问题在于人们太投入了。如你所知，人们只是忙于他们的，只是其他狗屎正在发生，他们只是去
like, yeah, that sounds great. Live forever. Okay. That sounds great. You don't understand. I just got insulted on Twitter. Right. It's true.
就像，是的，那听起来不错。长生不老。好吧。那听起来不错。你不明白。我刚在推特上被侮辱了。对。这是真的。
Those are the things that I think get the most attention is like, you know, the, the beauty product business is like a multi-multi-billion dollar. But then, but then you look at the existential issues like climate control and it's like, it's too far out there. If we do something that's really good today, we won't see the benefits for like 30 years. And this is the same with this stuff. By virtue, by very definition, most existential issue there is, is our existence. Right.
那些是我认为最受关注的事情，就像，你知道，美容产品业务就像一个数十亿美元的业务。但然后，但然后你看看存在主义问题，比如气候控制，它就像，它太遥远了。如果我们今天做一些真正好的事情，我们30年内都不会看到好处。这和这些东西是一样的。凭美德，凭定义，最存在的问题就是我们的存在。对。
So, so I will not be thinking about it. Well, if you're going to throw up, we can just pause for a second. I almost barked. You know, it's, this is the problem with you snacking while we're working. I was barking. God damn it. And you know one of those hamster, like the water bottle hamster things, he has one for food.
所以，所以我不会去想它。好吧，如果你要吐了，我们可以暂停一下。我差点就叫出来了。你知道，这就是你工作时吃零食的问题。我在叫。该死。而且你知道那种仓鼠，就像仓鼠用的那种水瓶，他有一个用来装食物的。
These aren't long sessions. You can go an hour probably without chewing, right? You know what, because, because I need to fuel this chassis because I'm running so hot. I'm running so hot. Maybe why not your shot a little bit? I know what I'm talking about. Let me. Oh, Lord, God help us.
这些会议时间不长。你大概可以一个小时不吃东西，对吧？你知道吗，因为，因为我需要给这个身体补充能量，因为我运行得太热了。我运行得太热了。也许为什么不稍微拍一下？我知道我在说什么。让我来。哦，天哪，上帝保佑我们。
All right, guys. Jason, that was, that's disgusting. Will just pulling up his shirt and it's great. Look at that. Guy, you got to get a job. You're turning a shade of tan that you're going to be on the street one day with that. I work with my shirt off. I'm pretty sure 18 hours in the sun isn't on Dr. Davidson Claire's list of anti-aging.
好了，伙计们。杰森，那太恶心了。威尔只是拉起他的衬衫，这太棒了。看看那个。伙计，你得找份工作。你晒出的那种肤色，有一天你会流落街头的。我光着膀子工作。我很确定在阳光下待18个小时不在大卫·辛克莱博士的抗衰老清单上。
You're good on vitamin D. The only reason I have 18 hours in the sun is because once it's the summer solstice, I moved to the Arctic Circle just to maximize sun per day. I'm, I'm so the opposite of you. Todd, my friend Todd calls me a human bounce card. Did I tell you that? Yeah, you are. I'm the whitest man.
你的维生素D很充足。我之所以在阳光下待18个小时，是因为一旦到了夏至，我就搬到北极圈，只是为了最大限度地利用每天的阳光。我，我跟你完全相反。托德，我的朋友托德叫我人体反光板。我告诉过你吗？是的，你是。我是最白的人。
Do you not go outside at all? You're not, you don't go swimming. You have a beautiful pool. I've swam in your pool many times, never, you've never been in it at any time I've used your pool twice and maybe 14 years. Is that true? Or 20 years? Jason, are you getting in the pool at all with your kids?
你根本不出门吗？你不是，你不去游泳吗？你有一个漂亮的游泳池。我在你的游泳池里游过很多次，从来没有，你从来没有在任何时候进去过，我用了你的游泳池两次，大概14年了。是真的吗？还是20年？杰森，你和你的孩子们有进过游泳池吗？
It was in about an hour ago. You were? I'm in it all the time. I went, I went for another long hike and stuff outside today. I worked out outside in the morning. What am I going to do? And I just attract sun and David, you guys got it. He didn't say.
大约一小时前还在里面。你在里面？我一直都在里面。我今天又去外面徒步旅行了很久。我早上在外面锻炼。我还能做什么？我只是吸引阳光，大卫，你们这些人明白了。他没说。
Sorry, hang on a second. You attract sun. You attract the sun. Yeah, yeah. I'm like, wow. David said, he didn't say. The sun looks down, sees will and says, oh, let's, let's shoot it over there. This guy, this guy's got more power than me.
抱歉，等一下。你吸引阳光。你吸引太阳。是的，是的。我当时想，哇。大卫说，他没说。太阳往下看，看到威尔，说，哦，让我们，让我们把它射到那边去。这家伙，这家伙比我更有力量。
Look at him. So David said, and according to David, he didn't even say it, but David said this guy's living forever and you guys saw it. He's got more power than me. That's so disgusting. You're disgusting. You're fucking gross. Thank you.
看看他。所以大卫说，根据大卫的说法，他甚至没说，但大卫说这家伙会长生不老，你们都看到了。他比我更有力量。那太恶心了。你真恶心。你真是太恶心了。谢谢。
I don't, I don't understand. You're so threatened. You're both so threatened and Sean, you said better than ever. This is the best I've looked. No, I don't think he did say that. That's true. That is true. You do look.
我不，我不明白。你感到如此受到威胁。你们俩都感到如此受到威胁，肖恩，你说比以往任何时候都好。这是我看起来最好的一次。不，我不认为他说了那句话。那是真的。那是真的。你看起来确实。
All right, guys. I love you. Okay. I love you. Okay. That was a great, Jason. That was amazing. I love that.
好了，伙计们。我爱你们。好的。我爱你们。好的。那太棒了，杰森。那太神奇了。我喜欢那个。
Great guest. Great guest. God, that was so cool. Honestly. Wait, are you both not going to be thinking about this? Should we once? All the time. Can we please go to Harvard, the three of us and let him move?
很棒的嘉宾。很棒的嘉宾。天哪，那太酷了。老实说。等等，你们两个都不会去想这件事吗？我们应该去一次吗？一直都在想。我们能一起去哈佛吗，我们三个人，让他动一动？
Wait, I'm not kidding. That would be nice. I'll do it. Let's do it. All right. Okay. Yeah. What, you guys have gone to, where'd you go?
等等，我不是在开玩笑。那会很不错。我会去的。我们去吧。好的。好的。是的。什么，你们去过，你们去哪儿了？
Bucharest together? Istanbul. Bucharest in Romania. Yeah, we went to. Well, okay. The next door, Budapest or Istanbul. And then we went to, we've also been to Venice, Italy. Venice, Italy.
一起去布加勒斯特？伊斯坦布尔。罗马尼亚的布加勒斯特。是的，我们去了。好吧，好吧。隔壁，布达佩斯或伊斯坦布尔。然后我们去了，我们也去过意大利威尼斯。意大利威尼斯。
So we can make it to Boston. We can make it to Boston. Yeah. We can definitely make it to Boston. Yeah, I'm going to fucking Boston. Very special two-parter at the end of the season. We're going to do it for sweeps. We already agreed, right?
所以我们可以去波士顿。我们可以去波士顿。是的。我们绝对可以去波士顿。是的，我要去该死的波士顿。季末有一个非常特别的两部分剧集。我们要为了收视率去做。我们已经同意了，对吧？
I'll fucking go there. I know fucking, as a matter of fact, I know a kid. His fucking mother used to work with me down in Dedum, Bud. He's doing his accents. This means we got to stop. He's turning into accents. Should we stop? Let's stop.
我他妈的会去那儿。我知道他妈的，事实上，我认识一个孩子。他妈的母亲过去在戴德姆和我一起工作，伙计。他在模仿口音。这意味着我们得停下来。他开始模仿口音了。我们应该停下来吗？我们停下来吧。
Okay. Okay, bye. Bye. God, it's the worst. I love how much weight we need today. Smart. Less. Smart.
好的。好的，再见。再见。天哪，这是最糟糕的。我喜欢我们今天需要的重量。聪明。少一点。聪明。
Less. Less. Less. Less. Less. Less. Less. Less. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
少一点。少一点。少一点。少一点。少一点。少一点。少一点。少一点。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。